ja wir kommen zur aktuellen sitzung
heute geht es um den begriff des guten
genauer gesagt um die natur des guten
bei einer neueren philosophin dem namen
philip erfurt
sie haben ein buch geschrieben die natur
des guten in deutscher übersetzung
und sie vertritt einen bis zur theorie
des guten das bedeutet für sie ist der
begriff des menschen ganz zentral die
kategorie des menschen das gute ist auf
das menschliche leben bezogen und der
maßstab des guten oder auch die
normativität an das was das gute zum
guten macht das ist die art die natur
des menschen
die gibt auch die normativität in rahmen
der beurteilung von gut oder schlecht
böse vor werden sie das für die parkuhr
in einem sehr
starken und gegensatz steht zu anderen
theorien des guten und des bösen wie zum
beispiel von derjenigen bei mangel kann
dann mache ich auch oben rechts die
grenze der sitzung zunächst das böse und
dann auch noch das gute bei kant und wir
werden sie nie gibt's stark
unterschieden
die leitfragen inwiefern ist mit einem
wie food sagt trittbrettfahren wolf
etwas nicht in ordnung sie wird das böse
mit einem trittbrett fahren wolf
vergleichen was das genau ist werden
nach sie nie verhängt die moral mit der
natur des menschlichen lebens zusammen
wie könnte man dafür dass natürlich böse
verstehen und inwiefern ist noch fotos
diese das natürlich gute
problematisch das ist auch eine frage
die wir uns stellen weil das will ich
ein paar zitate aus ihrem buch bringen
sie sagt ich kam zu der auffassung dass
es unmöglich war das besondere an der
idee des guten zu erklären ohne dass man
über die besondere art und weise nachdem
wir die wälder liegen riesen beschreiben
also ob etwas gut ist auch im
moralischen sinne aber jetzt erst zum
allgemeingut das hängt damit zusammen
wie wir lebewesen beschreiben gut und
lieben hängen ganz eng zusammen sagt
weiter ich denke dass zuschreibung
gefahrgut ausnahmslos auf die welt der
lebewesen als auch pflanzen tiere
menschen bezogen sind und da ist die
vorstellung von gut und schlecht oder
der mitte des lebens inhalts er wäre
einem universum in dem es keine
lebensform geben wäre nichts entweder
gut oder schlecht man kann nur annehmen
etwas diesem unfruchtbare universum sei
gut oder irgendeine weise wertvoll wenn
man stillschweigend auf etwas beziehen
das ist in unserem universum gibt bzw
geben könnte in wirklichkeit sprechen
manchmal davon dass etwas bei bestimmten
arten von lebewesen gut ist wie zb
kräftige wurzeln bereichen oder
schnelligkeit bei fluchttiere und wir
könnten auch davon sprechen was bezogen
auf bestimmte arten von lebewesen gut
ist wie zum beispiel besondere
nistplätze verfügt und
selbstverständlich ist unser bezug auf
das menschenleben oder wir beziehen uns
auf einzelnen menschen mit besonderen
bedürfnissen und interessen die
moralphilosophie nster würde ich sagen
ist nichts anderes als ein zweig einer
untersuchung des gute das in einer
besonderen und allgemein weise zum
menschlichen linken gehört wie genau
könnte das gute das moralisch booten zu
menschen die im leben das ist die frage
in diesem buch schreibt sie habe das
erklärte ziel eine auffassung
moralischen urteilen zu vorzustellen die
sich erheblich von der auffassung der
meisten heute schreiben den vokal
versuchen unterscheidet viele dellen
ihrer zeit liegenden mit moralphilosoph
finden und philosophen vertrat die these
dass das gute nicht mit dem leben zu tun
hat sind nur eine form des jähnigen
ausdruck wie wir über etwas sprechen ob
ihr natürlich emotionen ausdrücken oder
etwas befehlen also mehr auf die form
und die sekte nein wir müssen uns
zurückbinden an das leben denn ich bin
überzeugt schreibt dass bewertungen
menschlichen wollens und handelns
dieselbe begriffliche struktur haben die
bewertung von eigenschaft und von zügen
andere lebewesen und nur nach diesem
modell verstanden werden können ich will
das moralisch böse schreibt als zitat
eine art des natürlichen defekts
anführungsstrichen vorstellen leben sie
den mittelpunkt meiner ortung stehen und
die tatsache dass eine menschliche
handeln oder die position gut ist wenn
ich einfach als eine tatsache verstehen
die ein bestimmtes merkmal einer
bestimmten art von lebewesen betrifft
das moralisch böse ist eine art des
natürlichen defekt
wenn wir darüber nachdenken was gut ist
für individuen unterschied zu seiner
guten verfassung womit wir bei der
einführung des nutzen begriff begonnen
habe dann müssen wir tatsächlich
anerkennen dass ich das was gut für den
menschen ist an dem unterscheidet was
gut für eine pflanze beziehungsweise ein
tier ist dort verweist gut auf den
erfolg im zyklus von entwicklungs
selbsterhaltung und farbtrends um das
wohl des menschen ins zu generis dennoch
halte ich daran fest seine gemeinsame
begriffliche struktur besteht denn eine
naturgeschichte haben wir nicht nur im
falle von ganz notieren im falle von
menschen in beiden fällen beschreibt
sich die liebe mal lebensweise in der
die jeweiligen individuen erreichen
fasst gut versuchst es gibt vage
aussagen die menschen machen kleider und
bauen aber wieso die sich vergleichen
lassen mit füllgrabe federn und bauen
messen und so gibt es auch aussagen wie
menschen für ihre regeln ein und erkennt
rechte an und zu bestimmen was im falle
von charakter disposition und willens
entscheider guten schlecht ist müssen
wir bedenken was gut für menschen ist
und wie menschen leben das heißt welche
art von lebewesen der mensch ist sie
bindet also gewissermaßen naturalistisch
man müsse genauer sagen mio
aristotelische
naturalistisch die moralische bewertung
von menschlichen praktiken strukturell
oder
begrifflich an die struktur
lebewesen ob die ihre art gerecht werden
und jetzt kommt die frage nach dem
trittbrett fahren in wolfs ich sage man
wird sicherlich nicht bestreiten dass
mit einem trittbrettfahrer wolf der
frist aber nicht an der jagd einnimmt
etwas nicht in ordnung ist dasselbe gilt
von einer biene die einen mac quelle
entdeckt deren verhalten anderen bieten
aber nicht mitteilt wo diese zu finden
ist diese trittbrettfahrer individuum
eines pcs der mit ihr zusammenarbeiten
sind ebenso defekt mit diejenigen die
ein schadhaftes gehört siehe oder
bewegungs vermögen haben also da tritt
eine privat iwe theorie des bösen namen
dass bei thomas von aquin gesehen und
auch bei beauty nach oben rechts den
dingen zu blut hinein das böse ist ein
defekt das moralisch böse ist ein
gepflegtes
lebensvollzug sowie ein wolf frisst aber
nicht mit jagt ein trittbrettfahrer
wollen ja das war die kurze
zusammenfassung dieser sitze in der
nächsten sitzung haben wir es mit
gegenwärtigen theorien des bösen zu tun
wir diskutieren zwei neue wird
philosophin susan nehmen und bettina
stangneth anhand ihrer jeweiligen
theorien zu ist nun in bezug auf den
elfter september auf diese
taten die dort begangen wurden auf die
bedeutung und bettina stangneth hat eine
interessante interpretation von einer
ahrens theorie des banalen bösen sie
geben dann mache ich auch ein link zur
letzten sitzung oben sein und sie hat
den begriff des akademischen bösen
geprägt den ich auch sehr spannend finde
weil er auch zeigt dass auch in
akademischen wissenschaftlichen
betrieben form des moralischen an der
tagesordnung sind dann bedanke mich für
die aufmerksamkeit und bis zur nächsten
sitzung